hello and welcome to this video playing
a GF now no name no name but I've got a
fantastic score against this this guy
four and a half out of five maybe
because we had this opening earlier you
know you're not playing a rubbish
opening and offer a draw sorry for the
Frank woods but this is just very bad
this black system.the stone wall against
a set up without g3 is simply not a good
opening the only thing it has going for
it it is very resilient so it can happen
that I mean what is quite substantially
better but it doesn't mean that you yeah
that you win every game yes as I said
it's kind of resilient blacks position
okay let's see here Bishop if for even
comes into mind but you probably will
take on on f4 yeah maybe just this move
the night quite often has a very good
spot on f4 okay so yeah that's actually
both moves are good I taking it upon it
both are good ok so do I want to place
your 5 or not i think i'm going to take
this opportunity and gain that gain that
space on the queenside ok
both captures are quite quite okay it's
not so easy to decide what to do I can't
think I'll go with g3 now no capture
this DRA I've heard what on earth do you
want if you have no time you just don't
enter the pool and I don't mind to
sometimes take a draw but not if they
play get such such bad stuff and it just
feels like they could offer the draw
because um yeah they recognized how bad
the position is okay so taking this and
now where do you go no I don't think I
need to prevent those e5 or f four moves
in this in this position I don't know
maybe it's still useful just to make
sure that those pieces don't get
activated at all he only has this h 5 h
for now left and this is mostly opening
up and file for me kids and take andrew
p1
I try to go to a six and then look a
rook b7
the eighth-ranked is also not bad if if
I do that okay but Quincy for FB should
be too that's not a problem at all ok
let's no no tactic here right and age
form doesn't just do much
is there something there that wins
directly can always have a look taking
and rugby seven maybe but okay there is
no need to be fancy so came here rook
takes f8 should win we had this win
right and the Queen check on the other
hand is a threat 21 ok Jack minutes
let's play that so we'll check here the
only thing that I'm asking myself is we
can go King g8 this is may be possible
now I have rugby aid yeah this is made
check he could have after this I still
at this move check this is an important
little trick yeah does this opening is
really no good yeah it's the stone wall
itself is ok but it should be played
against the g3 based setups or setups
where white has the bishop on c1 and not
outside of the pawn chain and here black
cannot equalize anymore and yeah there
are various ways to play up later quite
yeah so what model set up but it's it's
totally fine yeah both captures now are
good it's always tough to say the pawn
capture has the virtue of making 'if
I've completely impossible forever but
90 x f4 is also has a good square them
ok put this here h5 yeah this is losing
some time no just before yeah it's
difficult for black here I actually
expected him to take but ok g3 it wasn't
easy to decide I wanted to do I thought
about this also but I wasn't sure this
he maybe has f1 and this is not so clear
so I went this the computer um suggest
this one but ok here also why does
somewhat better Jim I don't mind the
Queen trade he went back 23 and now we
should probably try a five this is a
more interesting now ok after that ok
maybe if I i was thinking i'd take
Knight takes Knight therefore and there
should be better but yeah this is not
not as clear as it should be yeah
probably I should have played
differently then maybe ff4 immediately
talking edge one again no everything is
back in already gave me that exchange
and also now yeah but only has to make
sure that he enters with this with this
heavy pieces ok no way out um yeah after
after this the computer plays a quick
kingi one I would have played euchre
check a check after which this check
this should be winning easily somehow
why I can actually win Jackie so
and do this and then grab this check oh
maybe maybe this is easier yeah okay
yeah this opening is just it's just not
not very much playable okay thanks for
watching